ah
en algún lugar de la costa atlántica se
está llevando a cabo una operación de
manera discreta debajo de esta barcaza
es imposible acercarse más al barco
donde los buzos están colocando los
últimos metros de un cable de
comunicaciones submarino
incluso el director del proyecto
mantiene la distancia
hoy es la parte más crítica de la
operación han sido necesarios tres años
de trabajo para llegar hasta aquí los
trabajos de tendido de cables submarinos
duran entre tres y cuatro años el cable
de seis mil seiscientos kilómetros de
longitud llamado amistades unirá a eeuu
con reino unido y francia- se conectará
aquí en medio de estos pinos a través de
esta pequeña trampilla es un sitio
sensible no se nos permite interrogar o
identificar a los trabajadores por
razones de seguridad digital ya que este
cable tiene tan solo el diámetro de una
manguera de jardín transitar a los
correos electrónicos las llamadas y las
búsquedas de millones de europeos
los hospitales la administración pública
las empresas con el tiempo las
comunicaciones de la mayoría de las
personas que utilizan internet en
francia y en europa pasarán por este
cable en algún momento
actualmente hay 447 cables submarinos
que cruzan los océanos transmitiendo el
99 por ciento de las comunicaciones
mundiales así se intercambian miles de
millones de datos algunos de los cuales
atraen la atención de las potencias
mundiales en 2013 edwards know then
reveló que la agencia de inteligencia
estadounidense n seã vigilaba los cables
submarinos y hace unos días periodistas
daneses llegaron a la misma conclusión
revelando que las comunicaciones de
angela merkel y otros líderes habían
sido espiados por eeuu esto no es
aceptable entre aliados no hay lugar
para la sospecha entre nosotros una
práctica que francia condena
públicamente aunque también intercepta
las comunicaciones por cable submarino
la legislación francesa establece que se
podrá autorizar la vigilancia de las
comunicaciones transmitidas o recibidas
internacionalmente con el único fin de
defender
y promover los intereses fundamentales
del estado no sólo es legal sino que la
práctica está financiada lo que permitió
a la agencia de inteligencia francesa
contratar a 800 personas hace 10 años
para vigilar los cables por teléfono un
ex responsable nos cuenta es una mezcla
de herramientas técnicas y métodos de
trabajo extremadamente sofisticados
son cosas que éramos capaces de hacer en
francia- con nuestros propios medios y
nuestros propios fabricantes desde
aproximadamente 2007-2008
todo es legal
solo que el secreto entonces a quien
espía francia a través de estos cables
solo a los enemigos o también a los
aliados preguntamos al ministerio de
defensa por principio no comentamos los
métodos de inteligencia reales con
supuestos y añade que la protección de
los cables submarinos se ha convertido
en una cuestión de soberanía digital y
autonomía estratégica en el mar las
tensiones ya son palpables por ejemplo
las armadas occidentales están
preocupadas por este barco ruso el
yantar que fue visto merodeando cerca de
los cables submarinos alrededor de
norteamérica en respuesta a francia y
otros países están invirtiendo en drones
capaces de vigilar los cables en
profundidades de hasta 2.000 metros esta
experta
dice que algunos conflictos futuros
incluso podrían tener lugar en el fondo
del océano si los cables que conectan un
estado se dañen sus comunicaciones con
el resto del mundo se verán limitadas
aunque no se reivindiquen operaciones
ofensivas sobre estos cables las
potencias mundiales están en cualquier
caso demostrando su poderío en steam
nuevas ambiciones y programas de
vigilancia que podrían costar decenas de
miles de millones de euros el profundo y
vasto fondo marino sigue siendo un lugar
que los humanos no pueden controlar ni
asegurar